okay Liz Oh with your tiny purse unload  that purse for me Julia what is in there  Amanda she's got one man in the lipgloss  that's it a mint and a lip balm I'm in  annelid loss this is just secrets you  know just secrets Leonardo DiCaprio  secrets are in this tiny bag this has  been such a fun season for you with this  movie what does it mean to be here at  the Screen Actors Guild I don't even  know what to say I think it's  unbelievable  well I was just behind Jennifer Aniston  crazy tell me about your look tonight is  there a secret you wanted to be comfy a  little suit yes I've worn so many huge  dresses for the last couple of awards  things and it's been a handful so  excited be comfortable and Erin house  congratulations you're such a darling  I'm so happy for you  this purse is that's history right there  ladies and gentlemen no she already  opened it nothing just air just Talent  [Music]